bonsoir apatrides merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france ce soir les
autorités viennent dans que d'annoncer
un confinement total lui ne rêve plus de
deux semaines votre réaction il n'y
avait pas d'autre choix
écoutez depuis quelques semaines on voit
une augmentation exponentielle des cas
et comme on n'arrive pas à imposer les
mesures de distance à sion le masque
je pense que c'est le seul choise que
c'était le seul choix possible
maintenant ce n'est pas un confinement
aussi dulko début de l'épidémie les
restaurants sont fermés les balles sont
fermés les cinémas bien sûr les
rassemblements bien sûr mais les
institutions publiques continueront à
fonctionner et il ya certains secteurs
qui continueront à fonctionner
maintenant on n'a pas le choix
justement vous dites on appelle ce froid
pour pour quelles raisons expliquées
nous la situation au liban
concrètement le problème au début la le
confinement et les mesures prises ont
été très efficaces
on a confirmé pendant un mois et demi un
confinement total nous avons eu très peu
de cas et nous étions cité en exemple
et puis petit à petit le déconfinement
qui s'est fait progressivement abouti à
un moment donné à une résurgence des cas
maintenant il ya une chose très
importante c'est que la population
libanaise n'est pas très disciplinés les
masques ne sont pas toujours
bien mis il ya beaucoup de gens qui
réfute l'idée de l'épidémie de colonna
il y a eu des mariages qui ont été
autorisés des descentes des
rassemblements sociaux dans les plages
dans les restaurants dans les églises et
les mosquées
et donc il est évident que il allait y
avoir une deuxième vague et nous sommes
en plein voilà malheureusement l'état
n'a pas appliqué les amendes
vous savez une quelqu'un qui parle pas
souvent ce qu'il à une amende de 50
mille livres libanaises et
malheureusement beaucoup de gens n'ont
pas reçu ces amendes là alors justement
l'état
yanis démissionnaire de la santé qui
s'est exprimée nous sommes au bord du
bus du gouffre c'est ce qui se passe
dans les hôpitaux on imagine que
l'explosion du 4 août n'a pas arrangé la
situation parce que c'est de cela aussi
qu'il s'agit on l'a vu en france quand
on confine c'est souvent parce que les
hôpitaux malheureusement ne peuvent pas
faire face absolument absolument
il ya les hôpitaux publics qui ont des
lits de soins intensifs qui peuvent
hospitalisés les malades mais les
hôpitaux publics sont aujourd'hui
pratiquement débordés ils sont
pratiquement à 75 % d'occupation les
hôpitaux privés ont également des
services qui peuvent accueillir les
malades mais tout d'abord comme vous le
dites il y à des hôpitaux qui ont été
endommagé après l'explosion dont qui ne
sont plus fonctionnelles et les hôpitaux
privés qui fonctionne encore sont
saturés par les blessés de l'explosion
du 4 août
donc c'est ce problème là qui a incité
je pense le gouvernement à faire un
confinement total de nouveau alors c'est
vrai que les chiffres pour nous
européens français en tout cas ne sont
pas impressionnants 9000 758 cas 107
décès il faut ramener ça
comment la population de ventre pays oui
bien sûr vous savez aujourd'hui la
deuxième vague en france on compte entre
2800 2000 jusqu'à 3000 cas par jour pour
une population de 65 millions
d'habitants
nous nous sommes à cinq millions
d'habitants et nous avons 450 à 500 cas
tous les jours et 450 cas avérés
positifs mais en fait tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de cas qui ne sont pas connues et
qui sont positifs mais non testés donc
ramené à la population libanaise et
ramené au secteur hospitalier libanais
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup trop pour le
pays avec en plus tous les problèmes
annexes l'explosion et la crise
économique
les masques les tests où en êtes vous au
liban parce que souvent le confinement
est un petit peu le dernier recours on a
vu ça en france parce qu'on était
justement précisément mal organisé ce
que c'est le cas au liban
écoutez il ya des masques disponibles
vous avez des masques en quantité
industrielle
les tests également sont disponibles
n'importe quel hôpital ou laboratoire
peut faire le test
on fait beaucoup plus de tests qu'au
début donc de ce point de vue on n'est
pas en reste
ce qui est très important à appliquer au
liban ce sont les règles de dispensation
et les règles élémentaires que la
population n'applique pas
malheureusement aujourd'hui vous êtes un
médecin inquiet il ya évidemment le côté
médical vous déplorez on sent là le
manque de discipline de la population
mais il ya aussi vous l'avez mentionné
une terrible crise économique au liban
ça ne va pas arranger les choses
évidemment oui je suis inquiet je suis
inquiet pour différentes raisons tout
d'abord nous sommes tous encore sous le
choc de l'explosion
on reçoit tous les jours
des blessés qu'on en plus la crise
économique ne facilite pas les choses
et maintenant le colonat avec le
confinement va réduire l'activité
économique du pays ce qui n'est pas une
bonne chose donc quand les problèmes
s'accumulent et koné obligé d'affronter
plusieurs problèmes en même temps c'est
sûr qu'on est inquiet et bien sûr que on
sait plus par quel bout commencer et je
vous avoue que toute la population est
assez démoralisé merci patrick baz
j'appelle vous êtes médecin chirurgien
beyrouth bon courage en tout cas avoue
qu'au liban